bueno en este momento no avanza porque
hay que decir que esta marcha que
comenzó a las 2 de la tarde desde la
plaza de Italia ha sido muy cierto
inscrita por la policía que lava
deteniendo a ratos y es lo que pasa
ahora Estamos en una pausa de esta
marcha que están provocando algunos
desórdenes de un grupo de personas que
iban delante de la marcha han sacado
algunas barreras que estaban protegiendo
una construcción y también algunos
letreros de la circulación pública pero
en general una manifestación muy nutrida
recordemos de los sindicatos que se
realiza el margen de lo que es la huelga
en las refinerías y en los depósitos de
gasolina Así que en este momento hay una
tensa calor un término muy periodístico
que se usa que parece que no quisiera
decir nada pero en este momento sí que
lo es porque muchas personas están
quizás incluyendo que podría pasar
alguna cosa entre la policía y los
manifestantes